Les élus de la collectivité adopte le Plan
Départemental de Transition Ecologique et
Solidaire. Un plan qui fixe les grandes
orientations du département pour préserver
notre environnement et ses engagements pris
pour faire évoluer la société réunionnaise.
Un plan de transition qui s'est construit
autour d'une grande concertation citoyenne.
" L'objectif de ce plan est de démontrer que
le changement est possible aujourd'hui, donc
ensemble. Réussir donc ce plan avec l'ensemble
des réunionnais, on pense donc aux agents,
aux services, aux élus, aux entreprises, aux
associations, aux citoyens donc avec toutes
les forces vives et bienveillantes de La Réunion."
Les élus ont également adopté lors de cette séance
plénière un plan visant au développement de
la filière biologique sur notre territoire.
5 millions d'euros y seront consacrés.
" Le plan comprend globalement quatre
axes : le premier c'est de faire en sorte de
mobiliser du foncier préférentiellement donc
pour les agriculteurs qui se lancent dans
le bio. C'est d'accompagner effectivement
l'installation et la conversion en
bio avec à la fois la poursuite du
dispositif départemental d'aide à la
certification. Un troisième axe qui
vise à développer les nouvelles pratiques,
donc il y a tout un volet innovation qui va
être accompagné et enfin le dernier volet c'est
de permettre aux consommateurs d'accéder plus
facilement avec notamment la réalisation de
marchés spécifiques pour les produits bio."
Le Département reconduit son engagement au plus
près des communes et des CCAS avec l'adoption du
Pacte de Solidarité Territoriale deuxième
génération. 100 millions d'euros seront
alloués sur les trois prochaines années à
l'aménagement et au développement économique
et social des communes de La Réunion. Les élus
ont également adopté à l'unanimité une motion
relative à l'accélération urgente de la campagne
de vaccination contre la COVID 19 sur l'île.